let's take another call here here we go
hey theo this is a thomas getty from
fort worth texas tommy out of fort worth
i'm calling today because a buddy of
mine
is well i don't think addicted but i
think
getting a little bit too much into beth
he
has been a little too much into meth
okay onward
kind of dabbling in the mess here in
there i don't think he does
oh you mean he's messing around huh okay
i'll stop
every day but you know like every couple
of weekends or so
i'm finding out this dude's doing that
you know he's not like hiding it or
anything tell me about it and i tell him
dude that's not cool he's probably
stopped doing that
slippery slope um i don't think that's a
great thing
for this dude he's a hard working dude
he's a job and whatnot
he's a great guy meth's great if you
want to do
card tricks outside of uh
you know outside of supermarkets for
people to make a couple of bucks for the
rest of your life
then meth's great meth's great if you
want to
um you know if you want to
[Music]
wash your hands so much that you washed
your damn skin right off of them
then meth's great meth's great if you
want it to be wintertime and you don't
need a coat
because your body is at about 190
degrees then yeah
meth's great onward he just does that
you know and a couple of my friends have
approached me about it and
said that they're worried about it
because he's not really shy about the
fact that he does it he's never really
offered anything
but you know if he did it a weekend or
two ago or
he did it that day before he came and
hang out with us so tell us
which i don't know i think that's weird
well it sounds like he's like the most
confident meth guy ever really like he's
muhammad ali dude this guy's you
know
smoke like a butterfly shoot like a bee
this dude's on that meth
but he's fearless about it so he might i
mean here's the here's the
the things that can happen he could
become the greatest meth user of all
time
and really become a champion of the
sport you know he could become the dion
sanders of methamphetamines
or or
this dude could get caught in a
playground uh
taken apart the slides in the swings in
the middle of the night for no reason
so those are really the two options let
me hear a little bit more
so how what would you do how would you
tell your friend that maybe stop doing
the math thanks man love you
love you too man i appreciate the call
you know because it is hard to approach
people especially if you think they have
addiction
if they're struggling it's hard also
sometimes i remember i used to use drugs
and i would think other people
were using drugs too much did i remember
being high on cocaine and telling
somebody on cocaine bro you you got to
do less cocaine
they're like what bro you are you're on
cocaine i said oh
you're all right you're right
i would
i would maybe talk to an interventionist
man sometimes they cost money
but i would maybe talk to an
interventionist because it still
i just don't see how it can get better
unless something happens now i'm just
really worried that it could get really
get bad quick so you got to tighten them
up dude
put little cards around too say hey no
meth you know
knock knock who's there not meth
or start teaching that dude algebra and
come out with a new thing called
mathematics
and this dude is just a straight up you
know he's the
it's like a beautiful mind bro but with
methamphetamines
and he's out there doing it right and
winning contests and and winning
trophies and traveling around the world
and smoking meth and you know doing
rails of meth
and setting new prizes and being
a wizard and everything
and then he falls in love with a
girl somewhere in japan or something
and then her father probably kills him
or something
that's a that there's just and that's
like a best case scenario
so it's limited man is limited
opportunity i think for him
so i do think it's a good time probably
to speak to him and
and it is time to shut it down man
there's never a bad time to shut down
somebody's meth use
because meth is like it's there's only
one or two drugs
at the real end of the line you got meth
and you got smoking crack
nobody's ever been like oh yeah i'm
smoking meth and i also
and i also just you know won a nobel
prize nobody's doing that
so you got to get your boy off that meth
i would talk to him and if that's not
working then i would immediately
talk to an interventionist talk to
someone who works at a at a
narcotics anonymous group somebody who
could actually speak to him
but i'd find somebody maybe in recovery
who can maybe talk to him
if you can't reach him because somebody
should be able to reach him
and here's the thing when he gets better
man when he's not using it he will thank
you
and that's just a suggestion dude also i
don't know good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah